>> Bret: WE HAVE GOOD NEWS --
>> President Trump: WE HAVE GOOD
NEWS.
PASTOR ANDREW BRUNSON IS IN THE
AIR FROM TURKEY.
HE'S GOING TO BE COMING TO THE
OVAL OFFICE, MOST LIKELY, ON
SATURDAY.
HE SUFFERED GREATLY, BUT WE'RE
VERY APPRECIATIVE TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE, A LOT OF PEEP.
THERE WAS NO DEAL MADE.
AT ALL.
>> IT'S BEEN A ROLLER COASTER
RIDE.
WE HAVE BEEN FINDING OUR NEWS
OUT LIKE EVERYONE ELSE HAS.
WE'VE BEEN KIND OF GLUED TO THE
NEWS, JUST SEEMS SURREAL WE'VE
OVERJOYED BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM
REAL.
>> Bret: GREAT NEWS, PASTOR
BRUNSON RELEASED FROM TURKEY ON
HIS WAY TO THE U.S.
IEMGTS BEEN A LONG TIME, TWO
YEARS FIVE DAYS AGO HE WAS
DETAINED BY TURKISH POLICE
WITHOUT CHARGES.
TWO MONTHS LATER CHARGED WITH
MEMBERSHIP IN AN ARMED TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION FOR ALLEGEDLY
BACKING A COUP ATTEMPT IN
TURKEY, FACED 35 YEARS IN
PRISON.
JULY TAKEN FROM PRISON, PLAGUED
UNDER HOUSE ARREST.
IN AUGUST, THE U.S. PUT
SANCTIONS ON A COUPLE OF TURKISH
OFFICIALS.
TODAY, AGAIN, HE IS LEAVING,
TIME SERVED, THE SENTENCE.
RELEASING A STATEMENT, WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMITMENT AND EFFORTS IN
SECURING MY RELEASE.
MY FAMILY THANKS THE PRESIDENT,
THE ADMINISTRATION, AND CONGRESS
FOR THE UNWAVERING SUPPORT.
THIS IS THE DAY OUR FAMILY HAS
BEEN PRAYING FOR.
I'M DELIGHTED TO BE ON MY WAY
HOME TO THE UNITED STATES.
FINALLY A GOOD 23450US STORY ON
A FRIDAY OF A BUSY WEEK.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL,
MATTHEW, KAREN, OPINION WRITER
FOR THE "WASHINGTON POST," AND
MARK TEESON FELLOW AT AMERICAN
ENTERPRISE INSTITUTE.
MARK, GOOD NEWS STORY.
AND SOUNDS LIKE THE PRESIDENT
MAKING CLEAR NO DEAL WAS DONE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S HOW HE DOES IT.
IT IS A BIG NEWS STORY.
THE 17th AMERICAN BY MY COUNT
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS FREED
FROM FOREIGN CAPTIVITY.
FOUR AMERICANS IN NORTH KOREA,
AMERICAN AID WORK THEY'RE JIPT,
THROUGH UCLA BASKETBALL PLAYERS,
AND A TEXAS BUSINESSWOMAN IN
CHINA, A CIA, FORMER CIA
OFFICIAL IN PR TO YOU GAL,
AMERICAN CITIZEN HELD IN
VENEZUELA.
HE'S DOING INTEREST FAIRLY
CONSISTENTLY.
HE'S DONE INTEREST NOT BY GIVING
BRIBES, NOT BY SENDING PLANE
LOADS OF CASH TO FOREIGN REGIMES
THAT, CREATES AN INCENTIVE TO
TAKE AMERICANS HOSTAGE.
HE EXERCISES THE COERCIVE
ECONOMIC AND DIPLOMATIC POWER OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HE PUT CRUSHING SANCTIONS ON
TURKEY, SENT THE LIRA TUMBLING.
TURKEY FOUND A WAY TO GET OUT OF
IT.
>> AND THEY HAD ALSO MADE IT,
THE ADMINISTRATION MADE IT
PRETTY CLEAR THAT, THIS WAS
NECESSARY FOR IMPROVING
RELATIONS.
THE TIMING IS INTERESTING.
GIVEN THAT TURKEY HAS ALSO BEEN
TURNING OVER A LOT OF
INTELLIGENCE ON THE POSSIBLE
APPARENT MURDER OF OUR
COLLEAGUE, JAMAL KHASHOGGI, FROM
THE "WASHINGTON POST."
TURKEY COULD BE PLAYING SORT OF
A DOUBLE GAME HERE, TO SORT OF
POSITION ITSELF IN ITS RIVALRY
WITH SAUDI ARABIA.
>> Bret: MATTHEW?
>> THERE ARE REAL ECONOMIC COSTS
TO THE CAPTIVITY OF RECEIVE
BRUNSON, NO -- REV. BRUNSON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S METHOD IS
LEVERAGE THE ECONOMIC WEIGHT OF
THE UNITED STATES AGAINST
REGIMES DOING NO GOOD.
THIS IS A VICTORY, NOT ONLY FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION BUT ALSO
VICTORY FOR RELIGIOUS FREEDOM.
YOU CAN'T FORGET WHY HE WAS
IMPRISONED IN THE FIRST PLACE,
HIS MINISTRY.
A LOT OF CHRISTIAN IS A ROUND
THE WORLD APPRECIATE THAT HE'S
NOW BEEN RELEASED.
>> Bret: YOU MENTION, KAREN, THE
MISSING JOURNALIST, KHASHOGGI.
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT THAT
TODAY ON THE TARMAC AS WELL.
>> President Trump: WE'RE GOING
TO FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH
RESPECT TO THE TERRIBLE
SITUATION IN TURKEY, HAVING TO
DO WITH SAUDI ARABIA AND THE
REPORTER.
A LOT OF RECORDS ARE OVERLOOKED.
IF LOOK AT IRAN, SO MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES, SYRIA, YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT A LOT OF COUNTRIES ARC
LOT OF COUNTRIES' RECORDS HAVE
BEEN OVERLOOKED.
I WILL BE CALLING AT SOME POINT
KING SALMAN.
>> Bret: WHERE DOES THIS GO?
THERE'S REPORTING, MULTIPLE NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS, SAYING THERE'S
U.S. INTELLIGENCE SHOWING THERE
ARE INTERCEPTS OR CALLS OR
RECORDINGS.
TURKISH SAY THEY HAVE HEARD AND
SEEN EVIDENCE OF THIS.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE NOT BEEN PRIVY
TO THAT AS FAR AS WE KNOW,
CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THE OTHER THING, THOUGH,
THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN FROM THE
U.S. INTELLIGENCE, THE
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED, THAT
THE CROWN PRINCE HAD, IN FACT,
OKAYED AN EARLIER PLAN TO LURE
JAMAL KHASHOGGI TO SAUDI ARABIA
AND ESSENTIALLY ABDUCT HIM
THERE.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF SIGNS, A
LOT OF ARROWS, POINTING TO THE
VERY TOP, TOP LEVELS OF THE
SAUDI GOVERNMENT.
>> Bret: THIS IS HEINOUS, IF IT
HAPPENED, AND IF THEY FIND OUT
IT HAPPENED IT'S HORRIFIC.
FROM PEOPLE WHO LOOK AT REGIMES,
AND HOW THEY DEAL WITH THINGS
AROUND THE WORLD, IS THERE ANY
DAYLIGHT IN DEALING WITH THE
REGIME THAT IT TURNS OUT DID
THIS?
>> IT'S VERY HARD.
THIS IS, I MEAN, BOTH CRIMINAL
AND IT'S A BETRAYAL, PERSONAL
BETRAYAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS EMBRACED THE
CROWN PRINCE.
IT WAS HIS FIRST COUNTRY THAT HE
VISITED AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE MADE DEALS WITH THEM.
HE'S SHIFTED OUR FOREIGN POLICY
IN THE MIDDLE EAST AWAY FROM
COURTING IRAN AND BRINGING THEM
AROUND AND TOWARDS SUPPORTING
OUR ALLIES LIKE SAUDI ARABIA AND
ISRAEL.
HE PUT A LOT ON THE LINE.
MBS, IF HE'S BEHIND THIS,
BETRAYED PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Bret: MATTHEW.
>>> IT WOULD HELP TO HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT THE CROWN PRINCE
IS BEHIND IT.
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE EVIDENCE
YET.
EVEN THE PLOT THAT KAREN
DESCRIBED IS FAR DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT THE TURKS ARE ACCUSING THE
SAUDIS OF DOING, TORTURING,
MURDERING, AND THEN DISMEMBERING
HIM IN THE CONSULATE IN
ISTANBUL.
NOT IN SAUDI ARABIA.
I A LOT OF PEOPLE ON CAPITOL
HILL ARE LOOKING FOR ANSWERS AND
EVIDENCE.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER, THAT THE
SAUDI-U.S. ALLIANCE CARRIES
GREAT COSTS AND HAS CARRIED
GREAT COSTS FOR DECADES F THAT
ALLIANCE WERE TO BREAK, THERE
WOULD BE COSTS AS WELL.
SO, AS WE EVALUATE THE
PUNISHMENT, THAT SHOULD BE METED
OF THE IF THE CRIME IS PROVEN,
WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
WHAT THE MIDDLE EAST DOESN'T
NEED IS ANOTHER FAILED STATE.
>> Bret: KAREN, LAST WORD?
>> I THINK THAT IT IS INCUMBENT
ON US TO, FROM THE UNITED
STATES, TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO GET
A CLEAR ANSWER.
THE SAUDIS ARE SAYING HE LEFT
THE CONSULATE.